how's it going bros my name is Pierre
welcome back to Kathryn I started
playing this yesterday and I can like
I've just been wanting to get back into
playing it I really really was impressed
by it so yeah my happy to be back oh my
god alright no one with a pink scarf and
that haircut is gonna push me off is
that the [ __ ] again yes real
interesting how we only remember once
we're in here what's going on that makes
the story of the different worlds really
interesting let's talk to a few more
sheeps
dying it's not cool hopefully there's no
annoying guys like my boss
who's talking about an egg oh it's these
guys the Elvis in the [ __ ] we met
through that Tamar some cheap candy no I
want really you're not gonna teach us
anything the swing out Cassie in tight
spaces huh okay well teach me another
one yeah I know all right sounds like we
kind of get the gist already I just
really want to play actually I need to
know this kind of self some of them are
kind of self-explanatory although I did
struggle so much before let's just keep
going in let's sit down oh god I think I
saw something I could put this off only
make me suffer longer so dramatic
first question all right you bros
already our old men's stupid ha ha ha ha
which what a [ __ ] weird question I
mean I like to think that I'm not stupid
but I kind of see the point and stupid
is kind of relative or subjective I
guess not really I don't know
[ __ ] me I don't know what are your
breasts thing I'm gonna go with that's
right
yes I want to do the bad options
obviously yes have the same person drop
them in here the time to be worrying
about the other sheet not if you want to
survive listen I can hear the voice of
the one trying to take your life tonight
again another sheep is trying to [ __ ] me
over goddamnit
I'm an I can't wait to do the puzzle
part it's really fun or are we this
should be the last stage 5050 hahahahaha
what what about girls Oh what do you
girls say not not all men Wow so we know
that we're [ __ ] but girls are more
optimistic about us that's fantastic
oh my love that in gay um so yeah this
should be the final one right final
floor torture chamber
let's do didn't rest on that I really
hope you guys are enjoying this as much
as I am I think it's so much fun to play
just hanging out you know hanging out
with my brick is I love his PO guys oh
oh a bat monster I've cos only in Japan
there will there be a licking ass
monster my favorite monsters oh my love
oh god we better not [ __ ] out on this
one I don't want to get eaten by a
[ __ ] ass monster oh god it's coming
Iran Iran Iran Iran fan-fucking-tastic
better get goin and shall we not yeah
[ __ ] hell that thing is [ __ ]
terrifying
well can we mix like [ __ ] can I push
these I can't oh my God look at that
face you look like my next mistake loves
a game what why did I do that it's okay
oh it's really fast did I just get
licked by someone else [ __ ] that
doesn't make sense I lick [ __ ] all
right well we obviously don't have as
much time as I thought all right
where am I
my controls are inverted what the [ __ ]
oh now they went back oh my god
[ __ ] hell that thing is annoying as
hell all right we got a pillow that's
good come on good job heads you did it
oh my god that [ __ ] ass licking what
is it doing disgusting stop [ __ ] you man
please stop
oh it's Michael patrols checkpoint Wow
yeah yeah that's what I'm talking about
rose oh [ __ ] my ass out you go for the
money okay get that money that cash that
money sucks man
I think that's how the song goes what
the [ __ ] how am I gonna do this get that
money Alfa [ __ ] sake there we go
perfect nailed it
oh my god not this [ __ ] [ __ ] again
nail that look at that we're almost at
the top Russ I don't know what to do
here [ __ ] sake one more damn it stop
licking me you [ __ ] [ __ ]
where I can't see
okay I'm gonna use my spell turn old
blocks no more that should make this a
lot [ __ ] easier oh god maybe not my
[ __ ] controls are inverted there we
go
you know what money [ __ ] it give me that
money that cash Wow yeah yeah Fabrice oh
man it's so hard it feels so good
finishing this [ __ ] [ __ ] you bought my
butt monster oh my god look at that
[ __ ] thing
but comes out with [ __ ] like that
while the scars will remain Great Escape
oh my god that was horrible
that was just awful I'll never forget
that depth Roshan eight I'll never be
the same man as I once was but it's over
and we got the bronze of cheap the
breach heaps that was a joke somewhere
in there well then I said you called
it's been forever I shouldn't be making
videos but I just really wanna play this
game let's look at some enemy I think
we're gonna meet Catherine if I had to
guess we just wake up in a cold sweat
and now we don't remember anything
Oh her again why wait her name is
Catherine out some sideboob faithful
sideboob
boy so she just crashed here well I'm
more surprised than angry I just alright
I ran I ran I read I read our amazing it
was the first time I've ever done
something like that something like white
one what oh wait what did I do
you're gonna make me see we've got ten
seconds okay look why me because I like
you what about you Vincent what do you
think about I think you've really cute
what else what else I'm kind of jealous
of you you seem to live however you want
what do you mean Vincent you can live
however you want to just so long as you
never think of cheating on me Catherine
there's something I gotta tell you
what's with the door alright alright
alright alright alright alright we did
it press add a two accompanied and I
don't know why I do it like that that's
pretty lame
now we're wearing sunglasses just like
the bar man maybe he's one of the
earlier survivors now wait then he'd be
a hundred years old
maybe he wished for eternal youth quit
joking around and listen this is really
important okay
sorry this month I'm running really late
with the period oh my god what are you
thinking
why am i sweating I mean I have to take
responsibility right
come on say something of course I'm
happy
but I think our choice depends now on
you're happy that's good to hear to be
honest I was a little worried so hard to
tell what you're thinking sometimes
uh-huh don't worry about me I mean yeah
it's surprising it's not like you're
sure of anything yet right well yeah
what what difficult how does she know
which area hello you're breaking up
what was that just a call from work said
something at a bug but I got cut off
you know the reception isn't very good
in the office but didn't sound urgent so
not that you phoned did you get another
one huh oh this yeah the new model came
out last week
so it hasn't been that long since you
got your old one you could have still
used it didn't you buy a new computer a
little while ago - you always throw your
money away you're going to have to watch
yourself from now on you know what I
mean oh sorry well it's okay since
you've been working hard
after all I might have to take maternity
leave yeah you might home oh but I plan
to go back to work after having the baby
we'll just have to split up the
housework okay you can't throw your
clothes everywhere anymore we are so oh
no we're gonna pass out man what do you
do in a situation like this you know so
I'll be handling all our bank accounts
Oh what the [ __ ]
we're not married come on oh [ __ ] she's
in here I can't really hear well oh it
is her
Vincent you've been acting weird today
my parents will be available ah this
game is so funny
I like I said this before I honestly
can't wait to just be play the game and
see how it reacts differently depending
on my choices I mean nothing's set in
stone so would you tell her doesn't look
like you're happy at all
so you're finally tying the knot
Congrats papa
get ready to kiss your wife's ass for
the rest with his face late no liquor no
smoking no gambling no relaxing on
weekends because you've got to take care
of the kids really yeah having kids
sounds awful guys quit filling his head
with doom and gloom come on cheer up
raising a nice happy family is supposed
to be a good thing right a happy family
never had one of those before
I can't see it yeah well you're not the
only one that's irrelevant it's just
because of the way you two grew up so
Vincent what's this weird dream you said
you had yeah listening here tonight
weird dream why are you asking now I
really can't remember it anyway you
don't I was being chased by something I
don't know it was scary and you feel
like you didn't get any sleep at all
that night right excuse me what are you
doing here yeah few people know what
you're taught as a child
so you'll fall asleep is yeah sheep
rhymes with sleep or something sorry hey
boss another rum and cola please don't
be so rough on the guy one day we'll all
be old farts like not all of it anyway
you're having these weird dreams because
you're cheating
yeah I get that besides Catherine might
be pregnant right don't need to remind
me of that basest instincts there's a
man's basis and walk away it's about
what happens now Wow
please have fun while you still can bros
ah this game is so interesting I you
know the black haired friend I'm
thinking maybe he's the one that put put
us in this position was named Johnny
he seems very judge full of us and he
asked questions about the dreams which
is kind of weird and there's a part
someone that we know in real life put us
in this situation
alright let's talk to Johnny
yeah I keep getting it unintentionally
now can't change I'm just a stray sheep
in the field of life - you know he's
talking about stray sheep ten twice he's
really gone astray I never thought you'd
be one to cheat in the first place I
can't believe it myself either let's
talk to her land a real for you huh
you two have been together a while it's
about time congrats on having a kid
let's do something to celebrate
yeah he's a good minute she said she
wouldn't tell you unless she was really
sure they're gonna do the right thing
right
wait a minute I know but oh damn you
want to meet my parents and ask about
how they got married I go back home and
drink some strawberry milk kid come on
why you gotta go there let's talk to
Toby applications for the general public
for these space tours way too much my
paycheck
I can't even afford it down payment and
boy do I have a deal for you I'd rather
put all of my savings into lottery
tickets that invest in one of your
creeks have a drink all right let's
check our phone action what do we got
stage two
we read that time passes when you say oh
yeah we know this alright so there's no
new ones
let's walk around a little bit check out
I like hanging out around that same
people know these people are new let's
talk to them there's a cowardly method
that tries to subdue love through talks
how well that's one way to look at
stealing from a certain mean the trick
to a long-lasting marriage is frankly to
spend as little time together as
possible and we okay this is the
congratulations we could replace each
stage as well but I don't think you bros
want to watch me do that let's talk to
the cuffs extremely loose with his
relationships with women oh well you
can't talk about it like you're
unrelated to it in this lovely couple is
Daniel and
is he the guy Vincent Brooks what do I
know you
it's me Daniel we went to elementary
school together what what you don't
remember me oh so you're Vincent you're
different from what I imagined Wow
you see Vincent I'm different from back
then I'm not the one tagging along
now I'm the leader I'm the heir to a
successful business a business there huh
because of that wait heard your voice
somewhere was it yesterday yeah I wonder
I would say no but if again message
Katherine again which Katherine though
are you still at the stray sheep
haven't you been there every night
lately I thought you had an upset
stomach today why are you drinking again
please take care of yourself you're not
just living for you anymore don't but
it's important to be with my friend
stair-step assuming device' back Oh new
message
I need to figure out how to get the bad
choices got him [ __ ] up a lot lately
yesterday I had a strange dream yeah we
definitely definitely we go in there
whoa so everyone who's in there is kind
of like an alum problem Oh
same thing me raising a family doesn't
exactly sound like a recipe for suicide
why are we all in the same situation
where we're cheating weight and our
girlfriend is pregnant what the [ __ ]
well it's time to get shit-faced okay
well we only need to know by Cuba Libre
there are a lot of cocktails with the
names no no I don't know still drink
lemon and soda water okay
fiz refers to the sound the soda makes
that make sense sweet
so even lightweights can wash them down
like juice and that was the cocktail
trivia for tonight tea already what
would you like now I'll go for another
cocktail that the only cocktail we drink
well it is delicious if we get a message
the other Catherine are you how are you
doing are you still at work are you done
yet yeah I'm done what do you want know
can I change these gonna just send this
can't see you today though I'm busy so
there are two options I'm done I guess
sorry I'm still at work yeah I'm done I
want to send just this what do you want
yes that cake yeah Wow awesome okay so
now we know how to do that
let's talk to them what does pitiful
mean
I would have to say men we're horrible
people a lot of people say that when
asked whether they'd like to return as a
man or woman in the next life the
majority of people say they'd prefer to
be a woman really does have even
predicted that men will become extinct
it's the truth extinct
apparently the white chromosome is quite
useless compared to the X chromosome so
it's possible and what will happen to
the human race if men go extinct maybe
there'll be a system where women can
fertilize each other and bear children
men try just as hard to live their lives
to this in nature why does that sound
kind of haunted by stupid guys being
ground down by life I did something I
shouldn't have
what are you talking about yeah what'd
he do is the boss I must bear another
message is it from Catherine I
understand hey hey hey what here I took
any picture why not come on
all right well how about over here why
would that be the toilet have a [ __ ]
wank in the toilet or some [ __ ] with the
health can wash my face go out or enter
the stall so I go in to stall it what a
nice bathroom check phone now it didn't
okay I've got more all right all right
all right who took that picture like how
did she do that
should we to reply
yeah let's reply all right we've got
whoa what a picture all right this is
exactly my thing let's see why the other
options are don't you think this is a
little too much this is exactly my all
right all right all right all right all
right I fix it let's wash our face I
never understand washing your face in
public it seems oh my god that's like
why do people always do it do you really
ever wash your face in public
it seems like a trope that people use
just to make us understand that the
character is upset or something I don't
know I don't know man all right are we
done hanging out all the twins left
let's sit down and love it I don't know
why I really enjoy just sitting down and
talking why does he always have to go to
the bathroom he did say that he didn't
plan to marry her huh he's imperfect at
his job I just kind of assumed he was
the same way of private and school dated
girls that he wasn't fully committed to
all the girls said he was just too
defensive I asked him about it Toby hmm
come on that's not fair
let's talk to Johnny Johnny does that
mean better they're just more appealing
to be around because he's less of an
[ __ ] than you are we're getting a
call pick it out
no I wasn't I could have been there
mister seen someone else huh swear I
don't know what you're talking about
Oh is there cafe by my place why did she
call us we have another message sorry
maybe I was a little too harsh I mean I
did overload up [ __ ] already oh hello
you with stuff about maternity leaving
money but it's important so make sure
you keep it in mind okay goddamn it this
is the first time she's like nice she's
been kind of like weird and not that
appealing I kind of understand Vincent a
little bit I think we should reply to
this I know don't worry about it bye
I'm sorry too I just can't I'm just all
right fine
damn it ha ha ha well I know that's
gonna happen
I sometimes I just have to go with
what's right or wrong and wearing a
thong all right you must want to keep
playing going I'm sorry for if I spend
too much time on these what do they mean
I'm fine what's going on the drink there
there are some things that you shouldn't
run from but there are also things that
you should forget thanks Erica
take care of yourself - Erica the works
are hot okay not as young as we used to
be hey joking joking
catch you later I like his red pants
like we don't say bye to our friends
either it's such a dick move okay
I think another nightmare is coming Rose
it's the Oh birthday Vincent's room
I don't know why it's so popular to
steal smoke in Japan like they still had
the smoking area a non-smoking area in
restaurants why is he so obsessed with
that that doesn't staying the same seems
really boring to me to go back to work
after having the baby we'll just have to
split up the housework okay you can't
throw your clothes everywhere anymore
you're going to have to watch yourself
from now on you know what I mean right
what is he doing
fall asleep like that and I can't begin
someone calling us on the door hmm who
could it be
what time is it now the game doesn't
want to tell me 1:00 a.m. 9 more time
fourth day all right let's do one of
these levels and then I'll have to
probably end
Stage four inquisitions will challenge
your cognitive abilities okay sounds fun
nah man I think the reason why wait
look at those fat sheeps I think the
reason why I like the skin so much is
because it's I have not never played any
game like this one are they follow me
are they trying to kill me or some job
well that was easy
are they still following me they aren't
they hit each other though
can they hit me
they can
this is really confusing me oh okay they
can push each other up oh my god they're
so annoying
if that's what the man we pushing logs
this could be our chance to push him off
fantastic what
oh man that's annoying so hard I can hit
them too sayonara [ __ ]
okay well that makes it a little easier
they can't come up now I track them
[ __ ] genius paired strikes again
okay we got this easy they did tell me
to push blocks back but [ __ ] it life's
handing you lemons so make a lot bucks
look at that [ __ ] the sexiest [ __ ]
turning me on seriously
no [ __ ] Mike I'm making a [ __ ]
staircase here can't you see it there it
is
check pas line awesome bris [ __ ]
genius how does it feel to watch such a
genius played this game it must feel
amazing so riveting and awarding I hear
the bell that's Bob I I follow it
whatever alright well that obviously
wasn't part of the [ __ ] plan rocket
again there's always more room to [ __ ]
up
there it is look at that [ __ ] shed
actually never mind don't look at it
[ __ ]
see I just need to get up there somehow
I can't go there
one had to be sacrificed it hurts my
feelings but at least we did it okay
wait oh damn it fell down stop pulling
down please I need you a line that
seemed a unnecessarily dangerous we did
it Sugoi desu so amazing Chen Wow rabbit
Oh
all right friends so much fun playing as
always thank you both for watching now
it's a great time to leave it like show
your support and that way we can keep
keep doing this
so yeah Thank You buzz as always I'll
see you in the next one
stay awesome